hey Leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge t3c ja dieses Projekt lebt noch
und an alle die mich danach abonniert
haben nachdem letzte Folge online wurde
es ist ein Projekt mit dem spark of
Phoenix und wir hatten eine längere
Pause weil ihr wisst ja alle noch Sparks
PC hat übelst gerauscht das lag an einem
Hamster der im er in einem Laufrad in
seinem PC hatte der da alles angetrieben
hat die komplette Energie und so da
gepackt hat und dieser Hamster ist
leider verstorben von daher hat sein PC
nicht mehr funktioniert und wir konnten
halt keine Folgen mehr aufnehmen aber
mittlerweile hast du einen neuen Hamster
oder wie hast du das gelöst ich habe
gleich einen ganzen neuen PC geholt also
das mE hamsterad war so ungünstig hat
immer so viel Futter gebraucht und immer
schön ins Gehäuse gekackt deshalb habe
ich jetzt einen richtigen vernünftigen
PC der dann auch läuft wie eine ein ja
und dann lassen wir das so okay und was
ich als zweiten Punkt noch sagen muss
ihr kennt ja alle mein Rode ntna womit
ich eigentlich sonst mal aufnehme und
zwar habe ich dieses verlieren ein an an
an einen Freund von mir der möchte
irgend so einen Song bzw aunahme machen
und von daher muss ich gerade alles mit
meinem G35 aufnehmen ich hoffe einfach
euch stört das nicht das ist für mich
jetzt mehr du
Arschloch das ist für mich jetzt einfach
mehr Komfort und ja jedenfalls können
wir jetzt eigentlich direkt weiter Maen
oder genau der letzte Part ist dann bei
mir also es wird ja das Video und D
wahrscheinlich drauf gepostet sein und
der nächste gibt's dann auch wieder so
also wir wchsen uns wieder ab ne Haden
richtig okay so dann genau wir waren
soch du mal erstmal ich ich trau mich
das nicht ja klar also Spark g die
letzte Folge war auf jeden Fall bei
Dingens beim Spark phix genau und näch
die nächste Folge wird dann auch wieder
bei ihm sein also immer abwechseln
täglich ach Gott das ist furchtbar und
halt auch immer unten in den Video
Antworten und in der Beschreibung Link
zu seinem Kanal s alles also alles wie
früher ja ja klar volles Programm
natürlich auch bei mir wiederum dann zu
dir ne nicht dass du jetzt denkst ich
würde dich ausnutzen so ah Gott ich muss
eine Stelle finden so ich krieg keinen
Schaden jetzt
sehr gut na ja ich hab geschafft so
wieder chillen
Runde es gibt nämlich immer eine Stelle
beim Kaktus wo man keinen Schaden kriegt
es gibt mehrere ich habe ich krieg auch
gerade kein ich warte bis du da weiter
bist damit ich hier warte ich habe
gerade
ne ich habe jetzt warte sofort alle
Herzen so jetzt nein den Sprung habe ich
noch nie
geschafft und letzte Folge gab es auch
etwas lustiges und zwar war hier der
Kollege Eisengolem wo ist oh ja hat mit
uns gejumpt war sogar noch besser als
wir am Ende und der hat mich irgendwie
zweimal getötet weil der mich irgendwie
nicht mag ach da haben wir die letzte
Folge war mir so ein so die Hälfte
zwischen Eisengolem fight und ähnlichem
ja ganz lustige Witze mit dem gerissen
ich wollte ihm dann zeigen wie man da
hoch springt und dann ist er mir
hinterher gesprungen Mitte auf dem Weg
ist der dann auf einmal weggelaufen oh
verdammt also auch irgendwie ein
bisschen blöd dieser Typ na ja hat nur
Eisen im Gehirn
halt so ach m ich schaff die die Sprünge
gar nicht mehr na ja bei mir geht's
Moment man muss einfach weniger ich sag
mal so versuch mal so daranzugehen als
ob die der Sprung eigentlich kack egal
ist ob du schaffst oder nicht weil dann
schaffst ein
Potenzial prozentmäßig dann mehr als
wenn du denkst er W den musst jetzt
schaffen so eine Art wenn verstehst was
ich meine ich gehe mittlerweile drauf
und halt einfach die Taste nicht mehr
gedrückt und Fall dann runter das war
bei mir gerade das Problem ach so ne ich
mach wieder Schift immer einfach so
standardmäßig kleiner Finger bis er
abbricht kppt der bei dir super mit dem
potenziellen
ST einfach so ja doch ich schaffe schon
tendenziell die ein oder anderen Sprünge
mehr
ach okay zumindest komme ich jetzt immer
bis zum zweiten binade beim dr ich muss
die Stelle
finden oh Gott sehr
gut was los jetzt hier mit deinen mit
dein tendenziellen hier nur tendenziell
ist sowieso wenn man sich weniger Stress
drum macht dann kommt man weiter ist
halt so
m
ja ich habe es bisher nie weiter
geschafft als der dritte ich habe es bis
jetzt auch nicht weiter als den dritten
geschafft und wir müssen ja noch eine
ganz schöne Menge machen ne MS aber da
musst bedenken die letzte Challenge habe
ich dann dafür geschafft und dann musst
du jetzt die schaffen vor
mir du hast die letzten beiden geschafft
stimmt so warte ah das war schon mal gut
warte ich Gee mal hier rum Z
Abwechslung nein ach das war knapp das
hätte ich fast geschafft ja also irgend
ich ich fange so an eine eine
kaktusphobie zu bekommen ich auch ich
habe so ein Kaktus bei meem Zimmer
stehen und den den würde ich demnächst
irgendwann mal lieber so rauswerfen
springst du auch immer gegen ne dann
fängst auf einmal springst auch mal
gegen dein kaktusmer dagegen ja nee der
ist ein bisschen zu klein der ist dann
eher so handgroß
und ab ab 18 wä dann dann könnte ich ein
anderen Witz reißen aber den lass ich
lieber
mal lass es es gibt ja auch so coole
kakt die nicht weh tun sondern die so
ein plüchfell drumrum haben also ja
nicht plüchfell sind beart gell ja die
sind
behart okay lass mliche kak lass das
eklig okay also was ich von euch bitte
einmal möchte dass ihr mir in die
Kommentare schreibt ob ihr die Qualität
jetzt viel schlechter findet oder ob was
du chillst hier rum chill am Kaktus also
ob ihr die Qualität viel schlechter
findet oder ob ihr eher sagt ja komm
kann man eigentlich so lassen weil dann
würde ich in Zukunft schon das ein oder
andere Video mal hier mit dem G5
aufnehmen weil das komfortabler ist als
immer sich mit dem Kopf zum standmikro
zu
neigen ist schon ein bisschen besser
Spark hat immer noch das Übelste pro
Headset du chillst da die ganze Zeit und
guckst mir nur zu ey nee ich muss er mal
Leben Aufladen so und jetzt fällst eh
runter nee tue ich nicht ich hä jetzt am
dritten ich schau dir mal zu toll
Scheiße guck
zu ja mititten im Sprung wieder gehangen
und dann B nach unten nur weil ich
zugeguckt habe
ne so hier steht noch meine Tür klar ich
habe die extra markiert mit Lukas Tür du
hast die extra markiert ja mit dem
Schild mit ne mit ein Duftmarke weiß du
Beinchen gehoben und dann drauf ja das
dachte ich jetzt ja ich habe die
markiert ja markiert
ach mensch das kann do nicht wahr sein
hier nee kannst auch nicht weil dann
wenn du springst dann kommt so irgendwas
von hinten und zieht Dich wieder
runter ich mache jetzt hier dies Blatt
kaputt
so was war das jetzt ich hab ich habe so
so Dingens kaputt gemacht so aber der
Sinn war das jetzt das abreagieren an
das war jetzt Aggression auslassen
Aggressionsbewältigung okay einfach mal
hier so ein Blatt kaputt machen
ma ich auch im meinem echten Leben
einfach wenn ich irgendwie gestresst bin
Blatt aus dem vom Baum nehmen einfach
zerreißen
cool vor allem weil du auch of in der
Wüste bist wo so kleine Dornbüsche
wachsenen die Wüste immer wenn ich in
der Wüste bin und dann genervt bin ja
immer wenn Du drin bist wie oft bist du
eigentlich da so alle zwei Tage einmal
nee mittlerweile eigentlich alle drei
Tage weil ich finde nicht mehr so die
Zeit n in dieseraharer zu fahren ach so
ja stimmt ja we der Flüge würden W alles
teurer aber Glint soll auch ein
Flughafen mit in der Wüste gebaut werden
und ach so nur für dich damit du dann da
landen kannst privatfughafen ach so ja
jetzt schon gedacht so so ein
industrieflughafen schon die richtige
Transportstrecke da da sind werden ja so
viele Güter gebraucht in der Wüste weil
so viele Leute leben ja wie ist es
natürlich entwickelt sich immer mehr zum
Industriegebiet das ist da gehen immer
mehr Firmen sehen da wirklich die
Möglichkeit die Sonnenenergie zu nutzen
um ihre Maschinen anzutreiben ja aber
das Problem ist wie bekommt man den
Strom von der Wüste z.B nach
Deutschland
Kabel okay mit dem Kabel so dann kannst
du jetzt mal versuchen ein paar Taus
Kilometer langes Kabel von dem Sahara
nach Deutschland zu legen das habe ich
schon gemacht oder nach Europa das hat
aber nicht funktioniert weil weil na
ja das Kabel was ich hatte war halt nur
2 m lang und da ist mir dann aufgefallen
ja es ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen
zu wenig ja okay 2 m das ja das war
knapp das hat nur ganz knapp ein
bisschen über über übers Mittelmeer
gereicht ne oder wir legen einfach ein
wlanabel wlanabel genau für
Stromübertragung ach man ich schaffe das
nicht dann sind wir schon zwei ach so
jetzt übrigens an
alle dann sind wir ja zwei übrigens an
alle die UN das gerade geglaubt haben
ihr seid
naiv kann ja sein dass das irgendwelche
Glauben gibt immer so paar
echt ja also von mir weiß ich auf jeden
Fall ich habe gedacht das wä jetzt ernst
gewesen nein warte irgendwas habe ich
glaube ich mal gesagt in dem Video und
dann war das halt so total
unglaublich wirklich ausgedrückt
irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht mehr über
was ich da geredet habe ich glaube dass
ich meine Computermaus mal aufgegessen
habe und mir deswegen eine neue gekauft
habe und dann haben wirklich welche
geschrieben e du Idiot wie kannst du nur
Mäuse Essen ich so oh Gott
also da gibt seitdem musst du wirklich
alles zweimal sagen wenn du irgendwas
ironisch sagst also das ist jetzt auch
okay stimmt aber irgendwie auch man weiß
nie wer vor PC dann sitzt und dann
zuschaut ist immer so ein bisschen
beunruhigend und vor allem teilweise
weiß man auch gar nicht ob jetzt
bestimmte Sachen ironisch sind bzw
sarkastisch oder halt nicht weil man
sieht ja nie wirklich die Körpersprache
und die ist ja schon manchmal echt
wichtig um sowas zu verstehen ach ja und
nicht dass ihr jetzt denkt dass dass wir
denken dass ihr alle so drauf seid wir
reden hier von einigen igen Beispielen
extrem Beispielen wir reden dann nicht
von 100% unsere Abonnenten sondern halt
nur dann von weiß nicht 99 oder so ja es
gibt immer diesen 1%zent der dann anders
ist das wäre bei dir z.B der eine
Prozent wä ich als Abonnent und bei mir
wär es dann du der dann halt nicht so
drauf ist ja das war jetzt übrigens auch
wieder ironisch oh Gott ja das ist halt
so eine Sache wir werfen Regel immer so
mit Ironie um uns so wie so wie der
Eisengolem immer mit concraft das um
sich wirft oder ich mit Männlichkeit und
Scharm wo mich
werfe rund um die Uhr mm wo ist der
überhaupt dieser golemislem der hat sich
glaube ich ein bisschen verpieselt der
wollte eine andere Map machen weil wir
hier sind ich glaube der ist aus dem Tor
rausgeeiert ich such den warte der war
hier vorhin aber noch ja ja ist ja
rumgelatscht und jumpt jetzt andere Map
ohne uns das wär auf einfach hockt der
oben auf seem Turm hüpft so
weiter ja irgendwo war der hier ich weiß
jetzt gerar nicht wo egal ich schaffe
das jetzt so jetzt habe ich ja freie
Bahn hier ohne dich und Hop ja ansonsten
h ich Hal ein Vorschlag wie gesagt wegen
dening abkürzen und so zur Not weil wir
sind schon die ganze Folge dran also da
wäre ich jetzt auch für ja nee ist halt
so dass man da so ein bisschen Variation
hineinbringt um das spielgefüge zu
erleichtern ums jetzt auf schlau
auszudrücken oder wir setzen uns
Checkpoint oder wir machen einfach im
Creative Mode dann kriegen wir
theoretisch keinen Schaden
oder stimmt ich probier es mal
eben ne man kriegt wirklich keinen
Schaden dann machen wir einfach im
Creative Mode und hüpfen dann hier rum
weil das einzig schwierige war ja quasi
dass wir immer Schaden bekommen haben
muss jetzt aufpassen dass wir nicht mehr
fliegen gell nee nee ma ich nicht so ich
bin schon oben ja s da geht das auch
viel einfacher oh nein wrong way da
dürfen wir nicht h springen ah jetzt
bist du mir durchs Bild geflogen wenn
ich am Sprung W ich als ich im Sprung
war
so ah war falscher Weg ist aber echt
genial so ist ist nur halben weiß wir
kürzen nicht das ganze ab sondern wir
springen das jetzt tatsächlich ich will
es nicht cheaten nennen ich will es
einfach Unsterblichkeit nennen ja un
aufpassen dass mich auszusehen Doppel
der Taste drückt für fliegen das
Unsterblichkeit hört sich viel epischer
an so wir dürfen jetzt aber nicht ganz
rüber springen sondern wir müssen jetzt
von hier da drauf so ja du schaffst es
nicht mehr
so
nein so
ich hab's geschafft ach ja das ist die
letzte Etage die letzte stage für diese
Challenge viel Glück ich habe übrigens
Checkpoint geholt ne du kannst hinkommen
ach so ja wollen wir das H auch einfach
mal mit Dingens weiter Maen weil wir
sitzen jetzt allgemein an dieser Wüsten
Challenge schon drei oder vier
Parts jo können wir mal gucken es wird
wahrscheinlich schwierigste sowieso sein
gell oh Mann ich dachte ich kann nicht
runterschopsen niemals okay ich weiß
nicht ob es das schwierigste sein wird
weil okay man kriegt ja natürlich
schaden aber ich glaube bei den anderen
Sachen wird so sein dass wir viel
weniger Checkpoints
haben stimmt weil anders kann sich der
Schwierigkeit Schwierigkeitsgrad
theoretisch gar nicht mehr erhöhen
oder na ja wer weiß oh
Gott ja ich kann jetzt auch gar nichts
unter Challenge 4 vorstellen was sie
dann noch großartig anders machen
wollen nicht sind halt die sprüe einfach
ein bisschen asi
asi m
aslack nein oh Gott ich versuch das
gerade mal alles ohne sprinten zu
schaffen ohne sprinten na das kannst du
knicken das wird dann ein
bisschen ja es ist wirklich schwer egal
ich mach das einfach wieder mit wo bist
denn du da oben oh Gott du
hä ich Himmer noch am
Anfang ja Creative Mode halt ne kann man
besser jumpen ohne Schaden zu bekommen
so muss das sind die sprü nicht mehr so
schwer jetzt ist irgendwie alles voll
einfach im Vergleich we vorimmer so
schwer alles hatten ich schaff das
gerade das habe ich gesehen gell got ich
fliege immer nur wieder hier zum
Checkpoint wieso bist denn du auf einmal
wieder hinten was da passiert ich bin
auch runtergefallen ach so
da
aber jetzt geht's deutlich besser so ich
bin jetzt nein oh Mann ich wollte gerade
sagen so ich w Kaktus dann nein
undfallen
fail
fail und hier
gleich ist die Folge übrigens auch voll
ne ach so noch ein paar
Minütchen ja ich schaffe das jetzt eben
schnell nein
oder auch nicht eben schnell wenn man
das so sagt dann wird das meistens nie
was oh ich habe aus Versehen einen Block
hier oben kaputt gemacht beim Checkpoint
aber das ist nicht weiter
schlimm muss echt aufpassen wenn man im
Cre du muss wieder abreagieren gell ja
ich habe einfach nee diesmal war sogar
ein kompletter Sandsteinblock den ich da
kaputt gemacht habe und nicht einfach so
ein kleines
ne komm nicht um die Ecke rum oh Gott
bist du blöd das ist doch voll einfach
ja mach's vor pass mal auf ich bin jetzt
hinter dir mal gucken ob du es schaffst
und ich
nicht ich schaff's
immer ich bin SP ich hä gerade ich scha
alles ach so was sagt die Uhr jetzt
genau die Uhr sagt jetzt genau 15
Minuten und oh 15 Sekunden ich bin schon
wieder drüber wir sehen in der nächsten
Folge bei sp genau die nächste geh dann
wieder bei mir so tschüss und tschüssön